attention casimir 1 2 3
madame attention
excuse moi j'oublie les je ne sais plus
très bien ce que je fais thual trappe
oui c'est quoi le trac c'est bien ou pas
bien passé ni bien ni mal si la peur ton
certains comédiens certains chanteurs
avant d'entrer en scène un bon parfois
secteur est si forte qu'on ne sait même
plus ce qu'on dit ni ce qu'on fait c'est
je crois que j'ai vraiment ne t'inquiète
pas ça passera le moment venu allez
respire fin bush twain harrington aspire
avec l'autre profonde et moi explique
mes amis autres larissa y est ça vient
il est arrivé déjà il ne va pas tarder
j'ai fait tout mon possible pour tenter
d'arriver avant lui mais alors un après
mon image nous le move it le boulot là
là et moi j'ai tout oublié
je suis pas dans mon assiette à taizé
vous tous les deux je vais finir par
avoir le trac bonjour on l'achètera vim
ah oui bonjour à toi il aux enfants
[Musique]
non mais voir dans mes bras
oui oui doucement je travaille vous
m'écraser la khl a craqué et voulu
marcher sur le pied lui pardonne moi ça
grand ami mais votre lettre ce matin
avec conduire hors de mon lit et là je
vois de vous revoir me bouleverse et
bien tant mieux tant mieux qu'ils
venaient ceci est le manuscrit de notre
comédie musicale
parce que c'est une comédie musicale
c'est de loisirs avant pour écouter nous
discuterons après volée vous un soir le
titre la case du monde face à frau
serait ce pas avoir les asseyez vous pas
cela de lyon la nage voilà
nous allons vous chantez le grand père
du héros non non non je suis venu je
suis venu pour vous faire signer un
contrat pas où on veut faire passer
l'audition écouter ici c'est moi qui
commande la région si vous avez des
dix mois d hiver tiapé des tractions
c'est vrai nous allons chanter la
recette de la sagesse et le grand-père
de la première partie attention
[Musique]
je voudrais bien savoir comment ils vont
faire pour devenir sage être toujours
obéissant comme les enfants sur les
images
surtout quand on est comme moi avec des
rêves plein la tête qu'on a des gestes
maladroits s'il te plaît dix mois la
recette
en vérité fait plaisir à tous
et c'est gagné tu peux faire ça sans se
voir
les horaires
les gens autour de toi
m
12 à 3
[Musique]
arrive de temps en temps de partir en
claquant la porte ce n'est pas que je
sois méchant c'est la colère qui
m'emporte
c'est pas sa faute c'est certes y arrive
que je me bagarre avec les meilleurs de
microsoft un jeu ta peau sans crier gare
en vérité fait plaisir à tout ce que tu
es
c'est gagné que devient ce sont souvent
eux mêmes
tués lors de randonnées autour
serpa col s
quand je veux bien essayer
pour diminuer mes bêtises se faire
plaisir au monde entier ce sera dur pas
que tu dis
the la france au secret monsieur du snop
et leurs acteurs julie mademoiselle futé
compte aussi parfois des erreurs
à
fabien savoir comment il faut faire pour
devenir sage d'être toujours obéi sans
comme les enfants sur les images
surtout quand on est homo avec des rêves
on a des gestes maladroits mais j'ai
bien compris la route
[Musique]
eh
bien vous faire plaisir chers amis
j'ajouterai un petit contre un pour moi
merci merci mais vous savez il faut
beaucoup d'autres choses pour une
comédie musicale avec oiseaux et bien en
dehors de jules hié de moi même il ya
d'autres rôles vient le factor il ya
également force one
monsieur du snug mademoiselle futile 20
ma tante adélaïde bon donc l'archibald
et caetera et j'aimerais également oui
avoir cinquante figurants déguisés en
soldats romains durable je veux
seulement six décors un peu plus mon
dieu un éléphant j'aurais tellement
drôle une dizaine de chevaux n'ont pas
dormi quatre murs
[Musique]